bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin en direct sur
notre antenne une matinée politique avec
à partir de 11 heures la remise du prix
de la fondation chirac en présence de
l'ancien chef de l'état mais aussi de
son successeur à l'elysée nicolas
sarkozy doit être en effet s'exprimer à
l'occasion de cette cérémonie
c'est donc à suivre à partir de 11h sur
notre antenne mais tout de suite
direction l'hémicycle du sénat où se
poursuit le marathon législatif sur la
réforme de la poste bonne matinée à tous
sur public sénat
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi relatif à
l'entreprise publique la poste et aux
activités postales dans la discussion
des articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'amendement numéro 202 au sein de
l'article 2 à mon nom 202 vous avez la
parole monsieur le sénateur madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
faute d'avoir fixé dans la loi de
modernisation de l'économie le taux de
centralisation globale en référence à la
collecte du livret a comme du livret de
développement durable
le code monétaire et financier intègre
aujourd'hui des éléments suivants
je cite le taux de centralisation des
dépôts collectés au titre du livret a et
du livret de développement durable est
fixé de manière à ce que les ressources
centralisées sur ses livres et dans le
fond prévues à l'article l 221 7 soit au
moins égal au montant des prêts
consentis au bénéfice de logement social
et de la politique de la ville par la
caisse des dépôts et consignations au
titre de ce même fonds affectés d'un
coefficient multiplicateur égal à 1,25
fin de citation dans les faits on doit
donc en déduire que les 160 milliards
d'euros centralisés dans le décret de
décembre 2008 constitue donc les 125 %
de l'encours
des prix du logement social et à la
politique de la ville 660 milliards
d'euros représente 125 % de l'encours
concernés cela veut dire que 128
milliard d'euros en constitue l'encours
global 162 / / 5 est multiplié par
quatre notre proposition vise donc à
accroître cet encours centralisée en le
portant à 128 milliards x 1 4 c'est à
dire environ 179 milliards d'euros
ce relèvement non négligeable de la
quotité centralisée participe de
plusieurs objectifs
le premier et non le moindre est de
tenir compte de la réalité de la
progression de l'encours des livrets
défiscalisés les relevés mensuels de
l'encours tel que diffusé régulièrement
par la caisse des dépôts et
consignations montre en effet une
tendance générale à la progression qu'on
peut évidemment un culte et à la
banalisation du produit dans tous les
guichets bancaires malgré certains mois
de coller de décollecte relative en
clair pour eux certains moments on tire
sur sont éteintes pour faire face à des
dépenses de caractère quasi
incompressible
second argument en faveur de notre
amendement l'accroissement de la
collecte centralisée va permettre plus
nettement de faire face aux exigences de
financement des missions prioritaires
dévolu à la collecte des livrets
défiscalisés pour par exemple plus de
moyens dans la construction de logements
sociaux dans le crédit aux petites et
moyennes entreprises et dans l'effort
national en matière d'économie d'énergie
dans le cadre des objectifs du grenelle
de l'environnement qui peut en effet
s'opposer à tout cela personne sauf à
considérer que les intérêts privés de
quelques banquiers prime sur l'intérêt
général c'est donc pour ces motifs que
nous vous invitons adopté cet amendement
merci
avis de la commission avis de la
commission
si l'on rapporte merci madame la
pression le directeur général de la
caisse monsieur augustin de romanet a
lui-même estimé lors de la préparation
de la loi de modernisation de l'économie
que le taux minimum de 1,25 était
suffisant pour donner au fonds de la
liquidité nécessaire en pratique le taux
réel est d'ailleurs bien supérieur donc
la vie ne peut être que défavorable à
cette position
merci à vis du gouvernement
merci la même présidente nous sommes
dans la même veine que le premier
amendement dit hier soir donc même
position défavorable
y at il des demandes d'explication oui
monsieur d'anglo la banalisation du
livret a été mise en oeuvre pour
répondre à une injonction européenne qui
estime et de son point de vue que les
établissements de crédit disons
ordinaire souffrait de la concurrence
déloyale de la poster des caisses
d'epargne plus marginalement du crédit
mutuel et de son célèbre livrée bleue
dans cette argumentation était
évidemment oublier le fait que les
réseaux historiques avaient des
obligations de centralisation
particulièrement forte l'encours du
livret a étant notamment destinée à
assurer le financement prioritaire du
logement social
la loi de modernisation de l'économie a
établi la banalisation de la
distribution du livret a est à amp n'a
rabattu sur la question de la
centralisation
en clair les établissements de crédit
déjà banalisée c'est à dire les banques
de détail se retrouvait avec un nouveau
produit à diffuser sans obligation
particulière quant à l'allocation des
ressources correspondantes
nous avons indiqué que la collecte du
livret a et du livret de développement
durable avait progressé depuis le début
de l'année 10 2009 à hauteur d'une
vingtaine de milliards d'euros c'est à
dire quelque chose comme un peu plus
sain plus de 8 à 9 % de l'encours
initialement recueillis dans la pratique
les obligations de centralisation à
combes en réseaux historiques poste et
que d'état
on était largement maintenue ce qui fait
que le surplus de collecte n'a pas été
centralisée pour l'essentiel étaient
venus s'ajouter à la part des livrets de
développement durable 20 milliards
d'euros de collecte nouvelle ajoutée à
50 60 milliards de collecte initial non
centralisés cela commence à faire
beaucoup
dans les mains des établissements de
crédit y compris d'ailleurs pour la paix
la poste et les caisses d'epargne pour
leurs propres collègues de l'ex livré
codevi nous posons d'ailleurs ce jour
seuls éléments la question que vont nous
révéler les états annuel d'utilisation
de la colle est décentralisée quelles
opérations financières auront été les
pilotait repartir de ces masses
financières importantes par les
établissements de crédit soumis en vertu
du décret de décembre 2008 à des
obligations réduite de centralisation
les obligations de centralisation des
établissements de crédits ordinaires
sont largement couverts à priori par le
produit de la centralisation des livres
et codevi
de fait toute collecte nouvelle peut
être utilisé à discrétion si elle
provient d'un transfert de livrets à à
des réseaux historiques vers les
nouveaux réseaux distributeurs
elle est même susceptible d'éviter en
grande partie les risques de la
centralisation et ont donc l'opportunité
d'être recyclés ailleurs que dans le
financement de logement social s'il
s'agit de la première souscription
le problème est résolu d'office le
niveau de centralisation exigé par le
décret de décembre étant largement
atteint 2 par les obligations imputables
au réseau historique ce qui a nourri
pendant des mois les mois précédents la
banalisation du livret a
les publicités alléchantes de certaines
banques c'est tout simplement cette
perspective de disposer de ressources
peu coûteuse susceptibles d'être
immédiatement utilisés sur les marchés
financiers et à la fin de l'année 2008
comme au début de cette année
chacun sait que nos banques en avait
plutôt besoin mais les perles populaire
n'a pas vocation à venir ainsi au
secours des choix stratégiques des
banques
c'est aussi le sens de cet amendement
que nous ne pouvons
que vous invitez adopté madame beaufils
oui un petit un petit complément sur sur
cet amendement je voudrais rappeler
qu'un décret traduit les conséquences
pratiques de l'adoption de l'article 145
de la loi de modernisation de l'économie
sous des dehors en apparence technique
se décrète décembre a de fait consacré
la latitude laissée aux établissements
de crédit offrant désormais le livret à
deux pour ne pas affecter les ressources
nouvelles qu'elle en tirerait à toute
centralisation grâce aux effets de la
loi une fois rempli les obligations
collectif de centralisation par la poste
et la caisse d'epargne pour l'essentiel
le surplus peut être rendue aux
établissements de crédit être utilisé de
manière relativement général
selon ce que permet la loi de
modernisation
ça peut être bien sûr le financement des
petites et moyennes entreprises en
disant que malheureusement on a constaté
que ce n'était pas largement utilisé ça
peut être les travaux d'économie
d'énergie dans les bâtiments didier
ancien ce qui bien souvent d'ailleurs a
été utilisée par de grands du btp pour
faire de la réhabilitation mais pas
obligatoirement du logement social
on comprend mieux pourquoi dès lors
parce qu'il est toujours à l'écouté des
milieux bancaires le président de la bce
n'a pas tardé à réduire le taux
directeur les sommes rémunérés en effet
à 1,25 pour cent
coûtant 1,5 pour cent placé sur les
marchés financiers à 3 4 ou 5%
cela participe fortement de la remontée
du produit net bancaire
cet amendement vise donc clairement à
mettre un terme à ce qu'il faut déjà bel
et bien appeler un véritable
détournement de l'épargné populaire
c'est le sens de cet amendement que je
vous invite à appuyer bien je mets au
voile amendement numéro 202
qui est pour et qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté nous avons deux amendements
en discussion commune une 205 rectifié
monsieur non c'est madame beaufils bien
une madame la présidente monsieur
ministre chers collègues
cet amendement bien sûr est toujours sur
la centralisation des ressources du
livret a et du livret de développement
durable
le décalage en croise entre le niveau de
la collecte et le niveau des obligations
de centralisation créé une situation que
l'on avait fortement imaginer au moment
du débat sur la loi mais néanmoins
surprenante mon collègue jean claude
danglot rappelé tout à l'heure pourquoi
le livret a avait été banalisé je n'y
reviendrai donc pas mais je voudrais
rappeler que le niveau de collecte
centralisée a été fixé à 160 milliards
d'euros est largement couvert à priori
par les deux réseaux historiques
cela laisse dans la nature des sommes
considérables puisque rappelons le
l'encours fin septembre se situe
aujourd'hui à 256 milliards d'euros
malgré une légère contraction donc dieu
aux raisons qui ont déjà été évoqués ici
sur les 160 milliards d'euros de
ressources centralisées la poste à elle
seule en assumer plus de 6 66 milliards
d'euros fin 2008 et a dépassé les 73
milliard d'euros au terme du 1er
semestre 2009 ce qui signifie tout
simplement que l'essentiel de la
centralisation est en fait très
largement supportée par les deux réseaux
historiques de la poste et des caisses
d'epargne et que cette centralisation
plus importante que dans d'autres
établissements devient aujourd'hui la
source d'un avantage inconsidérés pour
les autres banques disent team
distribuant aujourd'hui livret a et
livret de développement durable
il s'agit donc aujourd'hui par notre
amendement d'accroître le volume de
centralisation des encours de ces deux
livres et et de faire porter cet effort
de manière prioritaire sur les autres
établissements de crédit qui pour le
moment semble avoir tiré des règles à
avoir tiré parti excusez-moi des règles
sur mesure que la loi de modernisation à
fixer voilà donc le sens de notre
amendement
je vais vous demander madame beau-fils
de présenter le 204 rectifier à part de
mémoire madame gonthier-maurin comme ça
n'a de grands la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
souhaitons dans un souci d'égalité de
traitement que la collecte du livret a
et celle du livret de développement
durable soient très largement
centralisée et que cette obligation
incombe clairement autant à la banque
postale qu'aux établissements de crédit
pour le solde nous récusons évidemment
la méthode aujourd'hui appliquée qui
consiste à mettre en oeuvre deux types
d'affectation du solde de l'epargne
premier étage de la fusée une
affectation prioritaire en direction du
financement des petites et moyennes
entreprises ou encore des travaux
d'économie d'énergie mais une
affectation qui n'est toutefois pas
intégral puisque aucune obligation n'est
fixée à cette utilisation
la salle publication d'un rapport annuel
ne préjugent en effet aucunement des
suites à donner et les sanctions pour le
moment existantes sont particulièrement
légère puisque tout le mauvais usage des
ressources des livrets défiscalisés est
passible d'une simple suspension de cet
usage pour un trimestre on sait de
surcroît que les ressources du codevi
qui était au coeur de l'absence d'une
centralisation ont de longue date été
largement utilisés par les banques pour
recycler des ressources
finalement en distribuer à d'autres
entreprises que celles visées à
l'origine par le livret pour notre part
nous espérons nous estimons que si la
centralisation date être plus importante
à l'origine elle ne peut être que être
consolidé par la proposition que nous
avançons la question de la
centralisation intègre
al des ressources tirées dans l'ancien
livret de développement durable et du
livret a doit être posée encore une fois
et nous devons tendre à y parvenir avec
l'adoption de cet amendement
il faut accomplir cette étape pour
rendre par la suite toute sa vertu à la
qualité de l'épargné populaire en
déterminant des usages les plus vertueux
possible des ressources qu'elle permet
de lever elle ne peut servir comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui d'un simple produit
d'appel utilisé par certains
établissements de crédit pour détourner
cette épargne des circuits habituels
d'utilisation et de la retourner vers
des marchés spéculative les placements à
risque dans une poste où l'on souhaite
que 100% du capital demeure public
il faut aussi que 100 % de la collecte
de l'épargné populaire qu'elle assume
soit utiliser au mieux
c'est le sens de cet amendement merci
madame la sénatrice avis de la
commission
merci madame la présidente très
brièvement ces deux amendements soient
hors sujet l'avis est défavorable
monsieur le ministre merci à ma
présidente
très malheureusement ces deux
amendements sont sans lien avec le texte
est issu donc conduit est défavorable
monsieur fisher tu leur apporterait
monsieur le ministre dise que nous
sommes hors sujet mais pour nous est ce
qu'il n'est pas aujourd'hui nécessaire
d'aller au delà du sujet traité et de
voir quels seront les véritables
conséquences car il est là le problème
vous ne dites pas la vérité vous avancer
à visage masqué et oui et à partir de là
et bien de toute évidence les sujets qui
ont été traités par les problèmes
j'ai appelé ça hier le racket de les
pagnes populaires
j'ai appelé ça hier finalement
l'utilisation et que ce soit si vous
voulez dans le krach
banker où que ce soit dans le plan de
relance on voit comment est utilisé les
pagnes populaires et je crois qu'on
ferait mieux de revaloriser la
bonification du livret a que finalement
et bien tout le monde en profite et
notamment les petits épargnants
mais cela c'est un des points essentiels
le seul ministre alors nous ne sommes
pas hors sujet bien sûr vous voulez être
sourd aux remarques très pertinentes de
nos collègues et à partir de là et bien
croyez moi on va développer les
arguments et j'en ai encore quelques-uns
la madame beaufils vous aviez demandé la
parole oui je pense que lorsque monsieur
le rapporteur ou monsieur le ministre
nous dit que nous sommes hors sujet moi
je m'excuse
la poste c'est un groupe les questions
la gestion de la collecte du livret à
font bien partie des missions donc du
groupe la poste je veux dire on peut pas
considérer que parce qu'on discute d'un
aspect particulier il faudrait qu'on
abandonne une autre partie du
fonctionnement du groupe
je voudrais quand même rappeler que dans
ce domaine on a un montant précis de
centralisation à hauteur de 200
milliards
c'est notre proposition
je pense qu'elle est très sérieux c'est
une indication qui je crois mérite
d'être inscrite dans la loi puisqu'elle
confirme les choix que l'on veut par
rapport par exemple à la construction à
l'aide à la construction du logement
social
et je vois pas pourquoi on ne pourrait
pas fixer un tel montant dans un texte
de loi de ce type alors que sur un autre
aspect vous avez souhaité fixer en
termes d'aménagement du territoire
précisément les 17000 point poste donc
je vois je ne vois pas pourquoi
ici on ne pourrait pas revenir sur cet
aspect c'est d'autant plus important
nous semble-t-il que la généralisation
du livret à a fait en sorte que les
missions prioritaires qui sont
normalement défini par la loi pour se
livrer à n'ont pas été respectées donc
voilà le sens tout simplement de notre
souhait est de notre demande
d'inscription dans ce texte puisque
c'est celui qui nous permet de le faire
aujourd'hui ni madame gonthier-maurin
non oui je la mets président monsieur
lis mes chers collègues je suis surprise
comme mes collègues nous parlons de la
poste donc par essence nous parlons
d'une épargne populaire est précisément
notre amendement tend à poser et à
favoriser une juste une légitime et
juste allocation de la ressources
collectées à travers de cette épargne
populaire une légitime et juste à
locales au cas sion qui doit de fait
s'appuyer sur une centralisation intégra
c'était l'objet nous pouvons concevoir
en effet ici pour l'épargné publique
populaire des usages prioritaires
essentiels comme le logement social le
financement des pme les vrais parce
qu'ils sont dépendantes des grands
groupes
la mise aux normes énergétiques des
bâtiments publics comme des logements le
développement local
le dividende social peut permettre de
définir encore d'ailleurs d'autres
usages et la centralisation peut donc
être conçue comme intégral car il ne
faut jamais oublier dans le débat sur le
livret a comme sur celui du livret de
développement durable que c'est à
l'initiative du gouvernement français
que nous sommes passés d'une
centralisation de 100% sur l'encours du
livret à une centralisation de 70% est
en réalité certainement moins la réforme
du livret à telle qu'elle a eu lieu avec
l'adoption de la loi de modernisation de
l'économie a été présenté comme
découlant du travail de madame nelly
kroes dont on sait le grand attachement
à la concurrence entre établissements
bancaires
mais madame cros n'a jamais demandé que
l'on mette un terme à la centralisation
des ressources
de là est sa seule préoccupation était
de mettre un terme au régime particulier
dont jouissait la banque postale les
caisses d'épargné le crédit mutuel au
regard des autres établissements et
aucunement de mettre en question usage
de la collecte de cette épargne car de
fait aujourd'hui nous avons repensé
remplacer ce qui était une distorsion de
concurrence pour la commission de
bruxelles par ce qui est devenu un
scandale
en effet les livrets non centralisée que
gère les autres opérateurs de crédit
connaissent une rémunération non
négligeable à hauteur de 0,6 6 % des
encours moyen constaté qu'en dit que les
épargnants qui repartit d'une petite
incitations fiscales alors même que
l'allocation de la relou de la
ressources collectées est loin et
éloigné de l'objet initial
en clair on rémunère aujourd'hui avec le
fonds d'épargné gérés par la caisse des
dépôts les banques de détail d'analysé
pour ne pas affecter la collecte en du
livret a que du livret de développement
durable aux usages dédié le produit de
la rémunération des livrets défiscalisés
donc détourné de son objet et ce qui est
banalisée de fait le mauvais usage de
l'epal populaire cette démarche nous
mène donc tout naturellement à proposer
cet amendement que je vous invite à bien
je suis monsieur fourcade 1 je vous
remercie madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues à propos
de la poste dont nous devons débattre on
élargit le débat à l'ensemble des
problèmes financiers posés par la
collecte de lait par an et par le
financement des actions qui sont tout à
fait d'intéressantes certes mais qui
n'est qu' qui sont concerne qui concerne
beaucoup d'autres textes
alors madame le président bien entendu
nous voterons contre ces deux
amendements qui n'ont pas grand chose à
faire dans le texte mais je souhaite
avec la commission et le gouvernement
examinent les amendements qui vont venir
de notre point de vue au groupe ump un
grand nombre ressortent de
article 41 qui permet d'éviter de
discuter des textes qui sont de nature
réglementaire et je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse passer des jours et des jours à
discuter de textes réglementaires crois
qu'il est important d'avoir un débat de
fond sur l'organisation de la poste sur
ses moyens sur son implantation
territoriale sur le statut des
personnels voilà les vrais sujets dont
nous devons parler mais partir sur la
mécanique les mécanismes de l'épargné la
collecte et cetera me paraissent du
domaine réglementaire dont je
souhaiterais que la commission fasse son
travail de recensement de tous les
amendements qui sont présentés et qui
ressortent de l'article 41 bien
monsieur fisher monsieur le président
fischer droite la droite est en train de
montrer son vrai visage par la voix de
monsieur fourcade
voilà un avançait elle avançait je
disais à la bande mon précédent à visage
masqué mais avec l'intervention de
monsieur fourcade le masque vient de
tomber
et là il a vient
monsieur le ministre et bien alors j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour vous mais là
vous venez de sortir la grosse bertha
c'est à dire que vous venez de demander
à monsieur le ministre ou à monsieur le
rapporteur et à la commission et bien
d'user l'article 41 et bien entendu je
crois qu'il faut qu'on rappelle que par
cette injonction que voudrait mettre en
oeuvre monsieur fourcade est bien c'est
de faire tomber mais immédiatement sans
aucune discussion des amendements qui
ont traversé qui ont traversé le filtre
de la commission déjà parce que il y a
eu véritablement des débats les
amendements ont été présentés et que ce
soit le président de la commission où
que ce soit ils ne les ont pas fait
tomber parce que il souhaitait au moins
que le débat puisse avoir lieu
et ça c'est un des points alors si vous
voulez commencer de cette manière là
aujourd'hui
en cette matinée et bien croyez moi que
nous nous allons utiliser d'autres
moyens pour être retardée parce que ce
n'est pas nous ce n'est pas nous qui
avons retardé le débat vous avez pendant
48 heures était en nombre inférieur aux
représentants de l'opposition
et oui mais c'est la vérité monsieur
gournac vous étiez incapable d'assurer
votre majorité
et votre majorité est bien traduire en
effet le trouble des campagnes parce que
les élus qui sont ici savent qu'au delà
et bien c'est un problème qui est
vraiment le souci quotidien
ben vous défendez rien du tout vous l'a
démoli c'est la puce des arts
monsieur fisher pour aller dans votre
sens
mais nous ne sommes pas du tout en
retard moi je lis le document que j'ai
reçu ce matin qui nous donne l'ordre du
jour la poche procédure accélérée
voilà nous sommes en procédure accélérée
ici donc 1 et ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est effectivement les documents
officiels du sénat que nous avons reçu
ce matin même donc voir porter oui
puisque la commission vient d'être
interpellé
je voudrais m'excuser au nom de la
commission vis-à-vis nos amis
internautes qui nous regardent
franchement le sénat méritent un
meilleur débat et la poste mérite un
meilleur débat nous les le groupe
communiste a décidé de pourrir les
débats ok avec des amendements hors
sujet ce qui n'est d'ailleurs pas le cas
du groupe socialiste qui n'est pas le
cas du groupe socialiste la poste mérite
un meilleur débat voilà je m'excuse
auprès nos amis internautes le sénat
d'habitude peut légiférer avec des vrais
débats aujourd'hui malheureusement le
groupe communiste a décidé de prolonger
les débats avec des amendements qui
n'ont rien à voir à la défense de la
poste et du service public bien monsieur
testons
merci madame la présidente moi je
demande à ce que la sérénité revienne
dans cet hémicycle la question du
changement de statut de la poste
la question de la suppression du secteur
réservé qui peut avoir des conséquences
extrêmement lourdes sur le financement
du service universel postal mérite un
débat serein mais ce débat serein doit
se tenir
il faut absolument que nous puissions
échanger nos arguments vous êtes
favorable et vous l'avez manifesté hier
un changement de statut nous y sommes
opposés alors j'aimerais me tourne en
jean pierre focal pour qui j'ai aussi le
plus profond respect lui poser la
question de savoir ce que signifie
réellement ce qu'il a laissé entendre
dans son intervention
s'agit-il pour vous d'essayer d'abréger
les débats parce que vous trouvez qu'ils
ne vont pas assez vite
est ce que nous devons interpréter cela
comme un signe annonciateur de décisions
qui pourraient être prises dans ce cette
assemblée mais peut-être aussi en or de
cette assemblée par le gouvernement
qu'en est il réellement
nous nous tenons à pouvoir continuer à
examiner sérieusement ce projet de loi
et c'est en tout cas l'attitude que nous
continuerons à voir
messieurs bourquin j'oserais dire
j'aurais dire mon collègue cornu que la
véhémence de quelques propos il faut
l'adresser à celles et ceux qui nous
oblige et retraits dans des conditions
déplorables
est ce que c'est normal que nous
abordions un sujet aussi grave que la
poste que l'aménagement du territoire
que
la plus grande entreprise publique
française comme ça en procédure
accélérée et que ce que nous allons
aborder aujourd'hui qui est la présence
postale qui est le service public tous
le secteur réservé vous n'allez pas nous
faire aborder ce dossier là à une
vitesse grand v
parce que un ou deux hommes pressés
voudrait que le parlement ne soit plus
qu'une chambre d'enregistrement
moi je crois que je vais dire à mon
collègue cornu que vous ne devriez pas
accepter que ces projets de loi passe en
procédure accélérée
vous ne devriez pas accepter quelques
quel que soit notre position sur les
bancs de cette assemblée il y a des
dossiers qui mérite qu'on s'y arrête et
qu'on travaille sur ces dossiers et je
trouve profondément regrettable que
systématiquement tous les projets de loi
maintenant passe en procédure accélérée
mon collègue fourcade j'espère que vous
le déplorez je vous en remercie mais
faites le savoir faites le savoir
et puis parfois même et parfois alors on
a un ministre qui hélas ça ne peut plus
durer
c'est plus du travail parlementaire
hélas quand on va aborder il ya des
amendements qui sont fondamentaux qui
auront des répercussions dans tous nos
territoires
vous ne riez pas comme on les aborde à
vitesse grand v parce que le temps
presse
on a décidé de siéger ce week-end on va
siéger ce week-end mais on ne peut pas
passer ces amendements l'un à vitesse
grand v parce que des gens sont pressés
au dessus et qu'ils veulent et qui
traite le parlement d'une façon qui
n'est pas normal dans une démocratie
épanouie monsieur mirassou
merci madame la présidente est il utile
de préciser que je suis en plein accord
avec la déclaration de michel destot et
de martial bourquin procédure accélérée
il est vrai que d'asie notre vie le
ministre le plus concerné je veux parler
de monsieur estrosi était un homme
rapide 1 maintenant voilà qu'il vient
presser mais tout ce qui a été dit tant
la créditer la thèse sur laquelle la
poste c'est écrit doit distribuer le
courrier six jours sur sept
admettons avec un peu de facilité que ce
débat puisque nous occupe et 7 jours sur
7 et donc très tranquillement
c'est ce que nous vous demandons et les
amendements qui sont proposés par
rapport aux sujets qui nous intéressent
et sur cet article
un rapport peut-être pas quasi direct
avec le texte mais en tout cas
puissamment en direct et si la poste
veut revendiquer son statut universel et
bien ces amendements de fait ils
trouvent toute leur place et monsieur
connu une emboîté par la sémantique qui
a prévalu pendant deux jours ici parce
que vous risquez vous même de produire
un effet parfaitement contreproductif
par rapport à ce que vous souhaitez
c'est un conseil amical que je vous
donne ma dame hermange
oui nous ne sommes pas des hommes et des
femmes pressées nous sommes des
sénateurs patients hier soir et hier
soir nous sommes arrivés à 22 heures en
séance
il y avait inscrit sur l'article 2
environ 12 orateurs nous avons commencé
la discussion des amendements à 11h25
nous avons levé la séance à 00h05 et
nous avons passé deux amendements je
voulais simplement le rappeler au moment
où jean pierre fourcade est intervenu
pendant cinq minutes dans le débat nous
sommes très patients
madame jeune shelly
e
oui madame la présidente je voulais dire
à monsieur fisher que je le trouve bien
plus sympathique ans nous sommes en
commission des affaires sociales parce
qu'il s'adresse pas nous en dix ans la
droite comme si c'était quelque chose
qui était pas bien ce que je voudrais
vous dire ce que je voudrais vous dire
collègues n'interrompez pas l'orateur
soya ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est
qu'effectivement pour nous la poste
c'est très important
on y rit ce qui est faux cils débats
probablement ces camps en début de
semaine j'ai entendu dire ici que vous
êtes il dit on va leur pourrir la
semaine
là vous pouvez me sépare les deux
minutes oui à partir de là à partir de
la sadc très pénible de bus vous êtes
comme ça toute la journée on peut de
temps en temps parler de minutes
à partir de là on pourrait avoir le
soupçon que ce soit une stratégie
opérons tactique pour nous ici à l'ump
la poste est suffisamment important
c'est peut-être plus important encore
que vous le pensez pour nous et nous
pensons que la politique c'est sérieux
on ne doit pas faire d avoir des
attitudes théâtrales parce que les
décisions que nous prenons vont influer
sur des centres des dizaines de milliers
de personnes
est ce que je souhaiterais vous dire
pour moi la poste c'est même une
tradition c'est bien plus important que
ça au 100e et timo logique du mot en
latin traditionnel c'est-à-dire celui
qui transmet c'est vrai qu'entre le
facteur transmet lui aussi et nous nous
sommes très soucieux du sort des
facteurs j'ai été très touché par un
nouveau décès de vos sénateurs qui nous
expliquait le avec émotion ce qui était
pour lui le métier merveilleux de
facteurs qui exerçait son père alors la
tradition vous savez pour moi c'est un
progrès qui a réussi et je trouve qu'au
lieu de lire des papiers qui parle de
tout sauf de la poste et des personnels
de la poste
eh bien eh bien vous savez la tradition
et ce progrès qui a réussi moi je vous
proposerai plutôt que nous progressions
ensemble pour faire de la poste une très
belle réussite
madame blandin oui mes rêves la
présidente je voudrais que l'on revienne
sur le fond et je voudrais insister sur
le fait qu'à chaque fois qu'on propose
des amendements constructifs ils se
trouvent
un sénateur de la majorité pour brandir
un quelconque argument de procédure qui
retarde le débat hier j'avais déposé un
amendement sur une évaluation sérieuse
et comptable
le doyen gélard s'est mis à me dire
qu'il était normal qu'on avait des avis
négatifs parce que c'était passé en
commission et que la commission était
souveraine et que moi je n'y étais pas
et cetera ici nous avons un amendement
qui est passé en commission alors là on
dit ah mais la commission n'avait
peut-être pas pensé à sortir l'article
41 et c'est donc il faudrait que la
majorité arrête de retarder le débat sur
le fond monsieur courteau très
rapidement madame la présidente je peux
pas laisser passer ça madame vous avez
dit nous nous sommes sérieux mais nous
aussi nous sommes sérieux et c'est parce
que nous sommes aussi sérieux que vous
au minimum qui nous feront prendre le
temps de la réflexion et du débat
setteuse projet de loi qui est
particulièrement important
souffrez coni consacre le temps qu'il
faut et si vous trouvez que
effectivement les débats s'éternisent
comme l'a dit le président fischer vous
le pouvez vous en prendre qu'à vous même
pendant deux jours vous avez été
physiquement minoritaires la faute à qui
la faute à qui mais à madame terrade
merci madame la présidente on dit débat
de fond mais oui c'est un débat de fond
et le groupe la poste que je sache et on
est dans l'article 2 pour définir ses
missions le groupe la poste ces quatre
entités l'activité bancaire fait partie
à part entière de des entités de la
poste donc il est important qu'on les
définissent et dans ses activités
bancaires
la collecte du livret a avec toutes les
répercussions que cela que ce soit sur
le logement social que ce soit et c'est
important il est donc important qu'on y
consacre du temps bien je suis saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe crc il va être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour remettront aux
secrétaires un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
remettront un bulletin bleu ceux qui
souhaitent s'abstenir remettront un
bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants sur le 205 rectifié oui
petits papiers
voilà deux côtés
le scrutin est ouvert
non
la main jeu
la jeunesse
oui mais pas pour rien
m
à tort
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
il
et
m
il y a
je
en parallèle
numéro 35 sur l'amendement 205 rectifié
nombre de votants 340 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 339 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés 170 pour
l'adoption 151 contre 188 le sénat n'a
pas adopté pour le 204 rectifié mêmes
votes m vote amendement 194 rectifié qui
le présente le 194 rectifié monsieur
d'englos non monsieur le président
fischer alors cet amendement de notre
groupe portent sur la consistance du
service universel postal quatre
composants tel qu'il est défini par
l'article 6 de la loi de 90 consolider
alors cet article est un article le deux
essentielles de la loi postale d'origine
puisqu'il porte sur une donnée
fondamentale les obligations de la poste
en matière d'aménagement du territoire
et je voudrais m'appesantir sur ce point
là à vrai dire la poste et dans notre
pays la seule en situation de devoir
faire face à cette obligation qui tient
beaucoup pas la spécificité de pays
incident contrat de plan 2008 2012
nous est il rappelé et la loi a posé le
principe de la participation de la poste
à l'aménagement du territoire aux
moyennes son réseau de points de contact
en complément de ses obligations de
service universel et dans le respect du
principe de concertation avec les
partenaires concernés et je crois que si
tous les élus plus de 500 mille élus
dans notre pays sont attachés à ce
service public postal universel et bien
c'est parce que la france est le seul
pays d'europe dans lequel l'opérateur
prestataire de service universel des
envois postaux est chargé
de contribuer donc ça c'est la
spécificité française
alors qu'on nous le dise franchement est
ce que l'on veut plus de cette
spécificité
ensuite il y a la mission ou la poste
adapte son réseau notamment par les
points de contact la conclusion de
partenariats locaux publics ou privés en
recherchant la meilleure efficacité
économique et sociale
et puis il ya la fameuse règles
d'accessibilité au titre de
l'aménagement qui a été fixé dans la loi
de 2005 et j'insisterai sur un point que
je connais plus particulièrement c'est
l'implantation d'une part importante de
ses points de contact dans les zones
urbaines sensibles
plus de 1000 points de contact aux us
parce que nous avons cette france où les
inégalités territoriales les inégalités
géographiques les inégalités économiques
sont en train de creuser
et bien c'est cette présence postale en
zone de revitalisation rurale ou de
montagne de même que dans les zus et
bien contribuer au développement local
et à la politique donc de la ville on ne
serait effectivement mieux dire les
choses que de la manière dont elles sont
présentées dans le cadre du contrat de
plan
en effet la france ne ressemble
effectivement à aucun autre pays
européen puisque pour aller un peu vite
15 % du territoire sont occupées par 85%
de la population et 85% du territoire
sont occupées par 15% de la population
donc nous devons donc à tous les
territoires nos deux pays quelles que
soient leur densité de peuplement la
même qualité de service postal une
qualité de service qui passe notamment
par l'affectation des moyens humains
nécessaires au bon déroulement du
service public et par la variété et la
diversité des prestations et produits
proposés aux usagers
voilà comment ne pas pointer en effet je
termine là dessus que le développement
économique et social harmonieux de
l'ensemble du territoire passe par un
maillage renforcé de service public
coty de l'ouverture avec l'extérieur et
de progrès est un des points et je crois
que l'on peut peut-être tombés d'accord
mais ou tout du moins s'interroger de
plus ensemble
quand on voit la mise en oeuvre de la
révision générale des politiques
publiques avec les conséquences sur à la
fois la présence des différents
structures qui étaient appréciés par la
population
eh bien on voit se disent désertifier
nos campagnes des principaux services
publics
et cela je crois à travers la poste et
bien cela concrétise devient un des
points essentiels
merci monsieur le madame la présidente
avis de la commission on avait perdu
l'habitude madame la présidente excusez
moi alors de manière à essayer d'éviter
les provocations et pour prendre le
temps de bien dire les choses cet
amendement très longs semblent pour
l'essentiel vouloir supprimer les relais
poste chez les commerçants ainsi que les
agences postales communales ont ces
points de contact offre des prestations
bien utile en zone rurale avec une
amplitude horaire souvent plus
intéressantes que les bureaux de plein
exercice
nous ne pouvons pas donc comme nous
l'avons déjà dit en d'autres moments
nous ne pouvons pas être favorable à cet
amendement donc je vous propose de le
retirer sinon la vie sera défavorable
vis du gouvernement
merci dans la présidente je me dire à
monsieur fisher que je suis très surpris
qu'ils soutiennent cet amendement parce
que quand on ne lit et j'ai pris le
temps de le lire pour que le débat soit
vrai débat au fond et il nous dit que
l'efficacité du service public peut
passer par la mise à disposition de
locaux par les collectivités
territoriales
en fait il crée là une dépense pour les
collectivités territoriales qui ne mets
mon cher collègue
j'arrive à lire tout seul et je vous
remercie beaucoup de lettres que vous
m'apportez dans le cadre de la lutte au
tibet trice mme temps vous êtes un
spécialiste mais est resté de rester
dans la gratuité ça ira très bien donc
je vais pouvoir répondre comme je
l'entends elle se fit cher donc il y a
là une dépense créé pour les
collectivités locales
parce que même quand on dit peu la
pression sera suffisante pour que le peu
de vienne doivent et moi je suis très
hostile à ce qu' il y à une dépense pour
les collectivités locales nouvelle alors
que dans le système actuel c'est la
poste qui apporte une recette aux
collectivités locales
bien oui monsieur le président fischer
que la poste se ministre d'apporter
jamais la recette il y à moi je sais on
a eu notamment le problème de la
présence postale dans les minguettes et
bien c'est un des plus grands ensembles
français
cette présence postale était misérable
il faut voir les conditions dans
lesquelles fonctionnent ce bureau poste
eh bien il a fallu que ce soit la
municipalité qui rachète avec l'aide du
département mais qui rachète tous les
locaux et qui les met gratuitement à la
disposition de la poste et vous appelez
ça finalement
une non participation des collectivités
locales mais maintenant systématiquement
si on veut améliorer le réseau postal et
bien les collectivités locales sont
appelées à mettre la main à la poche
d'une manière ou d'une autre
donc c'est très clair et puis dans le
cher pour revenir à ce qui nous concerne
et bien je veux citer un exemple
ce sera pour cette fois le gères
département d'un peu plus de 180 mille
habitants dont les activités économiques
sont encore fortement marquée par
l'agriculture et la transformation de
ces produits avec une réputation parfois
flatteuse
quant à certaines productions sans
vouloir vous mettre trop longtemps l'eau
à la bouche
rappelez vous bien c'est le vieil
armagnac c'est le foie gras de canard et
d'oie et cetera et cetera
eh bien il connaît le gères reconnaît
depuis quelques années un regain
démographique et bien là on voit bien
que notamment le numéro le nombre de
bureaux de poste et bien est inversement
proportionnel à l'évolution
démographique l'exemple avait été pris
hier pour par notamment jean pierre bel
pour le département de l'ariège et bien
le gers est exactement la même procédure
qui a été suivie c'est à dire plus
la population augmente et bien on
assiste à une résorption coisy drastique
de la présence postale dans les
départements ruraux
voilà pourquoi nous tenons à nos
amendements madame beaufils
oui très très brièvement par rapport à
l'argumentaire de roger et qui vient de
nous être présenté moi je voudrais quand
même rappeler qu'aujourd'hui les
collectivités territoriales lorsqu'elle
décide contrainte et forcée devrez
installer la poste parce que celle ci a
décidé de fermer son bureau le maximum
de dédommagements qu'elle obtient et de
3000 euros
moi j'ai encore gelé pas apporté avec
moi mais je les ai dans mon département
une commune qui a voulu accompagner ce
ce désengagement de la poste
sauf que les frais à faire à l'intérieur
de la mairie étant tellement supérieur
aux 3000 euros qu'on lui offre 10 ans
claire va écouter
je ne peux pas le faire donc aujourd'hui
on se retrouve sans aucune possibilité
de répondre
deuxième aspect je voulais dit lundi je
crois mais j'ai visité 2,2 points poste
de poing contact samedi samedi il ya
huit jours les deux points poste
la commerçante elle va recevoir 257
euros
en termes de dédommagement combien la
post elle l a économisé dans ce cadre là
et on nous dit c'est une meilleure un
meilleur élargissement d'ouverture mais
il est évident que la poste quand elle a
fermé avait fait des horaires qui était
tellement incompatibles avec les
capacités des usagers qui est qui
l'entourent de pouvoir s'en saisir qu'il
est bien évident que c'était devenu
compliqué mais je pense qu'on ne peut
pas dire que les points contacts
répondront aux besoins et que les
dédommagements existent pour refuser
notre amendement
on a quand même dans notre texte poser
des questions de caractéristiques
démographiques sociales économiques avec
les zones de revitalisation rurale et
les zones urbaines sensibles qu'ils
étaient des éléments importants
justement d'aménagement du territoire
vous nous dit tout à l'heure vous êtes
hors sujet au rouge maintenant qu'on est
en dans le sujet vous n'abordez pas les
questions que l'on que l'on pose qui
permettrait justement qu'on ait soit un
petit peu plus efficace sur
l'aménagement du territoire monsieur
laménie merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
on peut partager dans le cadre de deux
évents suite à l'intervention du
président guy fischer là dessus on peut
aussi s'y associer d'une certaine
manière puisque il a vu aussi le
le coeur du problème le partenariat avec
les collectivités territoriales
alors le partenariat avec les
collectivités territoriales on peut le
voir sur tous les sens monsieur le
ministre tout à l'heure la rappeler les
10 le chiffre de 17 mille le bureau de
poste et points de contact je crois que
c'est réellement un chiffre qui est très
important puisque bon il rappelle quand
même la présence de la poste et surtout
la présence humaine
je crois que ce partenariat avec
l'ensemble des des communes qui
s'impliquent que ce soit pour créer une
agence postale d'un bâtiment communal
le partenariat aussi avec les communes
puisque maintenant en termes de
d'adressage les communes
mais surtout en particulier les les
villages qui n'ont pas forcément de deux
plaques de rues maintenant pratiquement
toutes les communes sont obligés de
s'équiper de deux plaques de rues pour
qu'une une si une signalétique tout à
fait convenable avec le le système
d'adressage informatisé et je crois que
à ce niveau là on est tous convaincus le
dit fisher a rappelé le chiffre de plus
de 500 mille élus qui sont sensibilisés
par la poste mais je crois que c'est
réellement tous les habitants tous les
habitants sans exception